345 exprimés 316 pour 201 contre 115 le
Sénat a adopté l'article 7
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une nouvelle preuve d'obstruction les 90
sous amendements de Madame Hubin qui
décale d'une journée la remise d'un
rapport ça n'est pas mesdames messieurs
de l'obstruction vous êtes en train de
vous
mélenchoniser jamais nous accepterons
que vous mélangiez le Sénat
l'obstruction ça n'est pas la démocratie
parlementaire c'est le Parlement qui se
fait Hara-Kiri c'est un 49.3 à l'envers
bien sûr nous allons voter cet article 7
vous espériez qu'on ne le vote pas ce
soir nous le voterons ce soir nous le
voterons parce que il va permettre de
sauver le régime de retraite par
répartition
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas
vous là de se débat essentiel sur le
partage des richesses vous battez le
débat pour dissimuler la vérité à nos
concitoyens parmi lesquels vos propres
électeurs
[Musique]
nous sommes heureux n'est pas le mot
je dis merci à tous les sénateurs qui
ont à la fois participé au débat de la
santé qui ont soutenu cette réforme de
la droite et du sang du Rassemblement
démocratique sociale et européens de
liberté et territoires de la majorité
présidentielle mais aussi les sénateurs
de la majorité Sénat sénatoriale Centris
et de droite
[Musique]